two years without a show and now
europe's biggest car maker germany takes
center stage ladies and gentlemen the id
live lots of razzmatazz and not a gas
guzzler in sight here attempting to calm
the nerves of around 808 000 german
workers dependent on the car industry
was the outgoing german chancellor
we want to pick up where we left off and
allow the economy to really catch up
again
this can already be seen in the motor
industry
even if some supply bottlenecks are
casting shadows at the moment
those shadows take some of the shine off
electric car sales the weakest link
isn't range anxiety or recharge
infrastructure it's the chip
many millions of desperately needed
semiconductor microchips to be exact
it's serious i mean there are
manufacturers that had to stop certain
production lines because they're missing
out some cpus that they have to build
into their car
and this will go on for a couple of
months
while the motor industry itself is doing
really well the shows to promote it have
crashed cancellations because of covid
have cost organizers more than 40
billion dollars
even before the pandemic the shows were
losing money so now although at first
sight you might not realize it there are
changes
it's shiny it's new futuristic and
contemporary but you might be forgiven
for thinking this is a car show
the organizers say no
a makeover is underway
corporate consultants have dropped the
word car from the event's name it's now
a mobility show and the consultants have
come up with what they think are catchy
questions
what will move us next for instance
maybe this autonomous bus or for those
of us old enough to remember the bubble
car although this one has its own brain
or electric motorcycles
powered pedal bikes
another question why are we here well
many big names from the united states
and elsewhere didn't show up to answer
that
the electric car is secure the road
ahead is green but for the mobility show
the future may not be a smooth run
andrew simmons al jazeera munich